it's game time at Berkshire eyes kids
Jersey Shore's Vinny Guadagnino is
turning up the heat for his Chippendales
residency I'm all about performing I'm
not someone who's shy on stage so I'm
gonna definitely go all-in and take it
to the next level
[Music]
Paquito Guido certainly took it to the
next level stripping down to nothing but
a single sock and not on his foot this
place is magical I mean it's a huge
production it's an actual Vegas show
it's not just a male strip club at all
there's dancing singing talent and it's
fun and this is the energy in the room
is amazing and as soon as I saw it I was
like hell yeah I want to do that and
it's not not that different than what
I've done before you know like step out
on a stage screaming fans and women
maybe take my shirt off the cuffs and
college is a little different dog that I
have to get used to Vinny currently
serves as guest hosts on perhaps the
steamiest stage in all of Las Vegas
through the end of May when I first
found out about Chippendales I was a
little apprehensive because I thought
Chippendales is a male strip club and
I'm like I'm not a male stripper but
it's so legendary and iconic I was like
I want to look into this further and
find out what it was so I kind of asked
a couple people about it including my
boy Pauly D after this Chippendales is
over like my run here I'm literally
going to the first I'm like diving
headfirst into a warm chocolate chip
cookie I might have sex with a warm
chocolate chip cookie after the show
you